- Eh bien, oui!
- Dans plusieurs régions
de France, une véritable
course vers l'essence.
Enfin, pour les automobilistes,
il s'agit plutôt d'un
exercice de patience.
- C'est catastrophique.
Voilà, moi, je suis pas sortie
du week-end parce que je savais
qu'il y avait pas d'essence,
mais là, j'ai été obligée et
j'en suis à ma quatrième pompe.
- On est lundi fin d'après-midi.
On se trouve devant l'une des
stations-services de la région
parisienne où on peut toujours
se procurer du carburant et
elles se font de plus en plus
rares, mais même ici, l'offre
est limitée. Et la situation
est encore plus critique dans
le nord de la France où
la crise perdure depuis
plusieurs jours déjà.
(coup de klaxon)
À Lille, cette station,
la seule de la ville qui
n'était pas hors service,
était très convoitée lundi.
- Moi, j'ai eu beaucoup
s et j'ai même pensé
d'aller plus loin, vers
la Belgique, parce que ça fait
trois jours que j'arrête pas
de regarder l'application
pour le
- Faute d'essence,
dans certaines régions,
les transports scolaires
ont été diminués ou simplement
interrompus. À travers le pays,
certains secteurs de l'économie
s'inquiètent des impacts de la
'est, par exemple, le
cas dans le domaine de la santé.
BRUNO BASSET, Assoc. de transp.
sanitaires urgents du Rhône
- On fait la queue pendant
une demi-heure, trois quarts
d'heure, une heure pour
faire le plein de gasoil
de nos véhicules qui doivent
non pas perdre du temps
à faire du gasoil, mais qui
doivent être là pour prendre
en charge des patients.
- On est des salariés qui
exerçons aujourd'hui un droit
qui est fondamental...
- À l'origine de ces pénuries,
des grèves dans les raffineries
des géants Exxon Mobil et Total
ie. Pour faire face
à l'inflation, les travailleurs
de Total demandent par exemple
une augmentation salariale
de 7 %. Ils exigent un ajout
supplémentaire de 3 % compte
tenu des profits immenses
qu'a réalisés leur société.
- L'inflation, tous les
travailleurs se la prennent.
- Total promet de devancer les
discussions sur le,
mais seulement une fois que
les activités auront repris
dans ces raffineries.EMMANUEL M,
président de la France
- Il faut que les parties
prenantes prennent leurs
responsabilités, les entreprises
et les chefs d'entreprise
concernés et les syndicats
s. Le blocage,
c'est pas une façon de négocier.
- La grève a été reconduite
d'une journée. Pour l'instant,
les négociations semblent
difficilement avancer.
- On peut vous promettre
tout com va reprendre,
ça va rentrer dans l'ordre,
mais rien de concret.
- Les réserves stratégiques
du gouvernement ont été mises
à contribution. Mais à quand un
véritable dénouement à la
de négociation? Sur les routes
du pays, ils sont nombreux
à se poser la question. Ici Raë,
Radio-Canada, à Paris.